this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
down minimalists
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life for
the last my name is joshua fields
milburn and i'm ryan nicodemus and
together we are the minimalists
we're here with the the second and a
half minimalist here yes
jessness williams is in the house
jessica lynn williams jess
thanks for being here thanks for having
me this is weird thanks for being head
you know today we're going to talk about
how the minimalists apply minimalism to
social media
we'll talk about how we've changed our
opinion about social media over the
years especially recently
and we're going to review the new
netflix documentary the social
dilemma and that's why we have jessica
here today jess manages all of our
social media accounts
for the minimalists i think we were just
talking the other day jess it's been
five years now to be six yeah soon we
started working together in june 2015.
wow we've known each other much longer
than that since 2012.
wow 20 yeah 2013 actually i want to say
yeah and so
i don't want this to be a diatribe
against social media although
i think parts of it might feel that way
today
uh because i think we met on social
media yes right
ryan i think ryan and sean are the only
people i haven't met on social media i
think
and so i'm i'm social
media in many respects but i'm also anti
the way it's being used the way that we
are using it
but also the way that it is using us now
and so i i wrote this question down
early on
is social media the original social
distancing
we've sort of been talking about this um
this concept of distancing each other
but
i feel like in a way social media has
connected us it connected us
but it also puts us at an arm's length
from everyone at some point you know
facebook friends are a good example of
this your average person has what 500
600 facebook friends
well dunbar's number is 150. we can only
manage 150 relationships at any one
given time and so jess i'm wondering
what
as we're talking through some of these
questions we've got some audience
questions as well
what are i'm going to be interested in
your your perspective
what you're seeing because you're closer
to this than
i am right now but i think we we have
probably similar opinions about a lot of
this stuff so
i want to talk about where we are right
now in 2020
2021 where we're going to be in the near
future
and also where we've been as you know
when ryan i first started the
minimalists
2008 is when we first discovered
minimalism 2009 right around there
the minimalist started in in 2010 so 10
years ago
right now we were facing this problem it
was post crash
this economic crisis
and a lot of people were realizing they
had debt and where'd that debt come from
it came from over-consumption
over-indulgent over-consumption and so
that was a problem and minimalism was an
old answer to a new
problem that was peeking its head out
and i don't think that problem has gone
away necessarily i think it's
morphed we have fewer shopping malls and
much more online shopping now
so consumption and over consumption
consumerism is still
a problem but there's a new problem that
i think has emerged over the course of
the last decade
during the the teens and that
problem is distraction it's not to say
that we weren't distracted before i
think we're more distracted
than we've ever been and
i've been thinking about this because in
that documentary the social dilemma
which we'll be discussing here in a
moment
that tristan uh tristan harris
tristan thomas is a cleveland cavalier i
believe uh
but tristan harris he is a former
ethicist at google
i'm a fan of his work i've been uh
following it for several years now
he says this isn't like the tv it's
different from
the television and i agree with that to
a certain extent but i don't know that i
completely
agree with that i think that
the television at one point was
pacifying
the average american average westerner
for eight hours a day
maybe more and now we've just replaced
that with a different pacifier
right and maybe it's a more pernicious
pacifier
but the thing we were doing before sort
of lacked meaning
in a way distracted us from that which
is meaningful
and this is doing so just much more
effectively
and i think the key problem with either
one of those is we're distracting
ourselves and i think that's really
where the problem is i don't know that
social media is a problem in fact i
would say the problem isn't social media
this is my opinion
i think the problem is constant
availability
and and what i mean by that is when you
left your house
20 years ago you didn't have
the tv following you outside the house
but now you sort of do whether it's the
notifications or just the constant sort
of
panic that you feel if you're untethered
from
that smartphone or someone at google who
called it the 79th organ
and it very much feels like
it's hard to become untethered to it
yeah
yeah it is actually uh you were
reminding me the other day was saturday
and
usually i try and stay away this week i
made an exception because i was driving
about for the week to come up here so
some of my work had shifted to be later
in the week but still in the morning i
was like
you know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
take a walk in griffith park i'm gonna
take my dog haven't done that in years
used to live out here so i really wanted
to relive that
and i so i got into the parking garage i
didn't have my phone
and i'm like well i know i lay pretty
well like the back of my hand because i
drove around so i know i can get to
griffith park
and i got lost smooth park
and i was like i was running late mariah
and i were supposed to do yoga and i was
so
i was so upset that like that i wasn't i
wasn't on time for that and
it's one of those things where i saw of
course like there's there's
this utility of this tool and of course
there's value in it but at the same time
god forbid if like i ran into a mountain
lion or a
person that didn't have the best
intentions like these tools serve us
and they do distract us at the same time
and i think what we really need to find
is can we get a net positive so like am
i actually getting something that's
going to benefit my life out of this at
the end of the day
yeah right yeah thank you that's my
famous saying
um so i got two thoughts going on one i
want to talk about the tv versus social
media i think this is really important
to talk about but
i think first let's talk about uh the
tool
that's something that really stood out
with me in the social dilemma
i think it was tristan who said we look
at this thing like it's a tool
but a tool sits around right and it
waits patiently for you to use it yeah
where social media is constantly
demanding
something from you yeah so it's not that
it
still can't be used as a tool bingo but
i think that sometimes we
i don't know we make an excuse well it's
just a tool that we use
yeah but the but the question is is are
we using it or is it using us
yeah i think we're here here's what i've
i'm speaking to myself here when i say
you i want you to
be clear about that if you have social
media on your phone you're being played
it's that so yeah and so i know we're
going to talk about some strategies
and some nuances but there are two
things that i want you to get out of
this episode if you stop it right after
this
number one take all social media off
your phone if you can and if you can't
take all personal
social media off your phone i'll make
that distinction there are business
reasons we can get in that probably
during the maximum episode we'll talk
about
whether or not social media is actually
beneficial for business and how it might
be
how it might not be as well so that's
the first thing
and the second thing is what our friend
cal newport calls the four-year rule
so uh or the fourier if you live in a
nice
palatial estate uh i don't have either i
have a very tiny hallway when you walk
into
my apartment i have a junk drawer though
as soon as you walk in it's in my
kitchen which is attached to that
hallway there and that's where i keep my
phone
now it's not that i never use my phone
when i'm at home i certainly do but
when i do want to use it i go and
grab the phone out of the junk drawer
there's a little friction
yeah creating that friction and even
then
i don't have social media apps on my
phone i also don't have email on my
phone
that's a choice and then it what's
happening i'm turning it back into
the tool that it was intended to be yeah
if steve jobs was in the social dilemma
very briefly
yeah and he certainly didn't intend for
this to be what it is today
yeah a distraction machine that is with
you in perpetuity
he was trying to merge a palm pilot with
a ipod
with a flip phone basically so that you
had all of this and you had a little
mini computer in your your pocket
the the the intention was never to
curate your attention to cultivate your
attention
as many hours as possible in order to
sell you
advertisements yeah he's liking it to
like a bicycle
for your mind or something right it kind
of reminds me it makes me think about
like when we're talking about this being
a tool and we think about
what actually is coming from this
experience of using this tool i feel
like it reminds me of like having an
amazon echo that tells you you're not
good enough
you know like it's like a tool that like
kind of assaults you
like in the middle of the day like it
kind of has an impact on your mind that
you wouldn't necessarily expect versus
like a hammer like
if you don't touch it nothing really
happens like it just sits on a table but
like social media is like a hammer that
comes up and hits you in the face
yeah like if you if you respond
to it in the way that it's designed for
you to respond to it well let's talk
about that tool because
i think that a smartphone can be a tool
and it can also be a a bludgeon in a way
where
it becomes this it becomes a hammer that
grows legs and chases you around the
place right
and you're like and so i think that the
tv was never
much of a tool right and and so we
recognized it
there's even euphemisms for the boob
tube or whatever right like it's
we we recognized that like that's where
i'm going to go
veg out we even use this terminology
like i'm a vegetable
standing in front of this like i'm not
animate now
now we veg out at a red light exactly
now we veg out in a waiting room
right there we've removed these
interstitial zones
the waiting rooms the red lights these
these the walks that we would take
without the earbuds in or whatever
where we would have time we'd make time
for boredom we'd make time for ourselves
uh we we'd make time to be alone with
our thoughts to sort of
yeah remember with the old pcs you would
defrag them do you remember this yeah
and so like
you have to run like a defragging
sequence on a computer in order to like
keep it
uh running smoothly and i feel like
that's where those interstitial zones
that's what they gave us was a sort of
defragging moment at the red light at
the
the airport lobby where you you didn't
have
access to constant contact and
and therefore people can constantly
contact you i mean now
if i have social media on my phone and i
even if i don't have the notifications
turned on there's the pool to say
did someone at me did someone like my
tweet how many
retweets did i get how many shares do
you whatever it is on facebook like
uh there are all of these these sort of
metrics that we're we're chasing
and we're chasing the wrong thing i mean
i think that's the craving
you know the the the buddhists called
the the four truths but one of them is
is craving and i think that is more
pronounced
than ever jess talk to me about the
social dilemma when you watch this film
what were your what were your initial
thoughts i mean for me
the first thing i thought was like well
yeah i kind of know a lot of this stuff
but i also thought they did it um
i thought the the documentary itself was
really well done and i've got some
criticisms
about the documentary i'm going to share
on on the maximal episode at least three
big criticisms but
overall i thought it was way better done
than i anticipated
i thought it was amazing i loved it i
felt like uh i was telling ryan like
these are these are like kindred spirits
like these people
they seem like in a lot of ways are
people because
they're seeing the result of of the
thing that they've created and what i
really
like about it too is these are the
creators of it and they're not so
attached to it
that they can't look at it with a
critical eye and say that
something that they have contributed to
has actually created a negative
environment in our society and i think
it takes a lot of like
introspection to see that your life's
work has done something so
um damaging but at the same time i also
think
um that we have a lot of good potential
to bring some good into the world and i
think that it was really beautiful that
it ended on a hopeful note
yeah yeah i can't believe how emotional
that movie made me it made me cry
wow wow i thought the exact opposite
fact if i had a fourth criticism
it would be it would be that like it
actually missed the emotion for me
like uh interesting i'll give you an
example and i know this is a
self-serving example if you look at our
our first uh documentary minimalism
like to me it emoted a sort of
it put me in an emotional place where i
was like okay what what am i supposed to
do with this emotion now like
and then it also gave some sort of
action there and i i think there
there were some sort of definitive
things that
the film said during the sort of credits
at the end of the film you can you can
try a few things
but it didn't really give us uh a viable
solution
yeah and i think what i want to do with
this podcast is i want to i want to
provide the solution because i think
they set up the problem phenomenally
well yeah
uh and i thought the the reenactments
they did a great job with those i those
could have been really cheesy but they
did a phenomenal job with that yeah um
and and also that you know the experts
including tristan
i mean they are they know what they're
talking about in fact
jess you mentioned like it is sort of a
noble thing and a really difficult thing
to say hey look my life's work
was misguided right ryan and i realized
that around age 30 where
we had climbed the corporate ladder and
realized the ladder was leaned against
the wrong building
and i think a lot of these guys in the
film and a few gals but
it was almost exclusively men um
who had developed these these products
to
garner our attention they realized at
some point in their life
like oh this is not what we intended
and it wasn't like there was some evil
cabal that got together and said how can
we drain everyone's attention
no no it was the opposite the road to
hell is paved with good intentions and
the guy who invents the like button all
of a sudden didn't realize the
implications
of having that in front of two and a
half billion
people what was crazy to me is like they
didn't
they never blamed any one person like it
was
and they asked that question you know
whose fault is this what's going on
and the problem is that there's so many
facets of it
that create the problem um can we talk
about that problem
yeah yeah so the i like that at the
beginning remember they said
what is the problem and at first they
kind of had trouble
explaining it's so good i love that i
love the hesitancy in it because it
really shows like they're
thick in it and they can't even answer
that question definitively
which is sad to me that that i i think
that
it is a rather complex problem let me
simplify it i think i think there are
three things i'd love to walk through
them
and there's more than three things but
there are at least three things that i
can identify as the problem right now
we already i talked about one in our new
book a lot of people use things i call
it
weapons of mass distraction right that's
really what it is the tv distracted us
when we're at home but now it's the
constant distraction we've already
talked about that
what but what does it distract us from
because
if we're getting joy and meaning and
purpose from these things then it
wouldn't really be a distraction right
right
it's actually distracting us from living
meaningfully
and so if we're not living a meaningful
life but
we're we're doing this thing that sort
of apes the form of
connection so it makes us almost feel
like we're doing something meaningful in
the moment that's a problem
second problem is we talked about it
briefly but it prevents us from engaging
with
and appreciating our boredom yeah
because boredom actually isn't a thing i
don't think
i think it's a reaction to over stimulus
yes
and and so and when you're over
stimulating boredom is like
it's it's the most uncomfortable feeling
well also we're both enneagram sevens so
i think that we probably experienced
that a little differently
right probably sorry but anyways no no
but i i mean yeah no
you're absolutely right we do experience
that differently well i think that um
rob bell in his book uh how to be here
he talks about
um if you're
bored you're boring right and
[Music]
i think that i think that for me what
that really means like
we shouldn't you can look at a monk
who's been in the room
for 12 hours
and he or she is not
bored right uh they've formed a daytime
with
in fact some of them can be elated
joyous
content at least right yeah beyond
pleasurable beyond
happy i mean that's your dream i mean
the weird thing is it's not and in fact
i think that's
i i wish it was i that's actually the
problem i wish it was
my dream in a way but right now i think
a lot of our dreams are misguided
remember shia labeouf don't let your
dreams be dreams
um because you like this fake
motivational speech for a role but uh
yeah uh i think that right now we
are the dream the the dream for me and
ryan
i believe is not to remove ourselves
from the contemporary
world like a monk or an aesthetic would
there's a lot of value in that but we're
trying to do is show that we can live
more deliberately
in that modern world right the third
problem
that i identified so we got weapons of
mass distraction we we've got
not appreciating boredom and the third
is
i think this is the biggest problem the
advertising model and they did a good
job of
highlighting the advertising model i
thought one thing was missing though
um the the advertising model
is there to make you do one thing it's
not just to garner your attention
it's i mean that that's the the
garnering your attention
is so they can feed you ads the point of
the ads
is to get you to buy stuff you don't
need right with money you don't have
yeah and maybe that's the implicit
message of that but i think it
gets lost in all of the other the bits
of
social media distraction ultimately the
point of
ads and thus the point of social media
because it's ad driven
yeah is to get you to buy things
you don't need so so how do they do that
they make you as just
alluded to earlier they make you feel
inadequate in a way
yeah yeah i'm sorry keep on going
no i would love to talk about the tv
versus
the smartphone but what i'll say about
the ads
that could be its own documentary that
could have been a whole other thing
um the uh the emotional response that
that
it gave me by the way because what you
what you elated to was
there was no emotion there was no
solution to the problem which
i get that for me it made me sad for
well hey the fictional family that was
there but the fact that
they represent a real family and it
represents to me
what a lot of people are going through
right now with with these distractions
and how
it doesn't seem like it's a big deal but
it actually is a it is a big deal
but let's talk about just real quick the
tv versus a smartphone so
um you said you did not agree with the
point or you weren't sure if you agreed
with what point
well what i brought up was that the main
way
that it is different from the tv
is i never really saw the tv as a tool
oh right
and uh yeah and i do see the potential
for a tool
don't get me wrong there are some there
is some potential as a tv being a tool
yeah
but really i don't think in our
lifetimes it's ever served as a as an
actual tool
yeah it has served as a as a pacifier
the phone itself is in many ways a tool
a gps tool it plays music
it allows me to connect with people on
the phone or via text message
and so in many ways it is a tool but
then it's also a distraction machine as
well
yes one thing that's really interesting
too i feel like when you're looking at
the phone or even
when i see people looking at the phone i
really try and not cast any judgment
because what's really interesting about
the phone is when you're looking at it
you could be looking at flight
information
you could be looking at a calculator
you'd be looking at your stocks you
could look
at banking and i'm not saying that it's
not pernicious and not invading our
lives but i try and
really look at it objectively and see
that this item that i'm holding in my
hand
is not really serving just one purpose
right
so because of that we kind of see
everybody in this zombified state but
it's interesting because from our own
perspective we're doing something of
value
so i think the importance is for us to
recognize that
we may think we're doing something of
valuable we have to be mindful of the
fact
that despite the fact that like you know
we have these algorithms
like we can't outsmart them because i
don't think that the algorithm
is about being intelligent like i don't
think that overcoming
it is about being intelligent i think
it's like it's taking advantage of our
humanity
so we just have to be aware that we're
humans yeah yeah i like that point it's
like if someone's if i see someone
texting
and i might be like oh they're there on
their phone they might be writing a poem
i mean it's yeah
yeah i like that giving the people
giving people the benefit of the doubt
and even then it's contextual right
because like
if you started writing a poem right now
as we're having this conversation
right it would it would be a distraction
but isn't it interesting if i was doing
this over here with a pen and paper
versus having my phone out it elicits
two i keep doing the same exact thing
but it elicits two completely different
responses although i think that's
generational i think that's beginning to
change
we're seeing a lot of gen z kids i guess
ella
my daughter is on on the ver the the
tail end of gin z
right anyone born 1996 or after
and i think they're probably going to
start seeing a little bit differently
with respect
now i'm not saying that's a good thing
right um
it's just that they're looking at it a
little bit differently there was a point
in the documentary um going back to the
tv thing there's a point in the
documentary where
i think it was tristan who was talking
about
the level up the leveling up the level
that this does
and someone was debating with him and he
said well
that's what they said about tv when it
first came out you know that's what they
said about x y and z and this is just
another this is just another version of
that yeah
the difference to me though is why it's
so incredibly different than what
television
does is it is it is there to
uh specifically take up as much as your
time
as possible like it is it is a
pernicious thing
and it's funny because we sit here we
blame social media and it is a large
problem
but even apps we have on our phone it's
still collecting data it's still
getting as much as it can from you to
make sure that
you know whatever search engine you use
is gonna like know what to sell you
i don't think that's a different problem
from tv though and in fact if you look
at the data
we spend about as much time now on our
phones
and tv as we did on our phones and tv
20 years ago right and that shifted in a
different direction in that sense you're
absolutely right the difference to me
is that tv did not have the effect on
your life
that that social media and that a cell
phone has on your life yes
in terms of self well it did it's just
probably not as pronounced right what do
i mean you didn't you didn't watch the
tv and want to cut yourself
you didn't watch the tv and be like oh
man like look at that person's life um
i'm gonna kill myself the tv didn't
bully you
yeah no i i think it did too many i
think it gave us an unreasonable
expectation
especially through advertisements yeah i
mean we can say i mean i'm i'm happy to
agree to disagree but i mean we can say
it's similar in that aspect
i don't think we disagree though oh okay
i i well and maybe we do but like
you would agree that advertising in the
80s still tried to create a
a false need yeah i think what i'm
trying to say and maybe we can agree on
this point
um we can say that social
or just cell phones in general
everything that comes with it smart
phones
they are similar to televisions
but like tv is not similar to a
smartphone if that makes any sense
because because it does so much more
than what than what a tv did
for sure yeah just you want to expand on
that oh yeah i mean one thing i just
wanted to say too is i think it's i mean
even though obviously watching tv is not
necessarily like a communal thing
uh all the time i think also in the home
number one you
a lot of times like i know we just had
kind of like maybe one or two tvs
so it was more communal it was a shared
screen number one so i think it was
communal in the sense that it was in the
home but it was also communal in the
sense that there was only like
there weren't as many options in terms
of things you could watch so what we did
is we
all entered the same world during a
certain time and now when we look our
phones because the algorithms
are different for you and you and me
we're entering different worlds when we
answer our phones and i think that
that's adding to
that level of isolation that you've been
talking about yeah
in fact i want to i want to play devil's
advocate against that because i think we
agree on this but also
i think there's a lot of good that comes
out of these algorithms so i'm going to
write this down so we can talk about on
the maximum we do need to move on to
some of these questions we have from the
audience brian in china has a question
for us
i left the u.s because of the constant
pressures of societal normality
religious views
and people always crossing boundaries
that you set as if it's a joke
or you're wrong my question is how do
you deal with the constant judging or
breaking of boundaries you set without
being almost
too aggressive so jess i think this was
a necessary question here because
brian sort of opted out of i don't know
western culture i i suppose
he and his wife um i know you don't hear
the entire voicemail but
he and his wife are living in china sort
of digital nomads
i'll be honest i don't really know what
that means so maybe you can enlighten
the uh
the uh listenership on what a digital
nomad
is i've heard the term a million times
and i sort of
smile and nod like i know what uh
they're talking about but he
the problem he had it sounds to me he
didn't use this word but tribalism the
the the the binary the you're on team
red or team blue team
r team d and there are a hundred
different examples of this team
conspiracy or
team uh i don't know uh round earth or
whatever like all of these these these
teams and he wanted to opt out of that
but
i also think that's sort of part of our
our human nature so
can we talk a bit about boundaries and
boundaries that maybe you set up during
uh with social media
and uh what what would you tell brian
well i think
um i think one thing that i would tell
brian is i mean
when we're thinking about social media
becoming a distraction i think that what
we're also
not thinking about is the overarching
like value of our life because when we
talk about minimalism we're always
looking for the why
and i feel like when you're deriving a
lot of value from your life
those distractions become less enticing
because you realize what you're
it's pulling you away from so i feel
like really placing emphasis
on those things that you value so much
and and
focusing on what your mission is in life
i think that that's one of the first
things that i would say that he needs to
do if i'm
you know he may have already done that
but like
that will give you the leverage as we
talk about to move forward effectively
so when you do hit a distraction you
know why it's important to walk away
from it
yeah i wish i had more information on
the boundaries that he's talking about
um i'm assuming i'm assuming it's
boundaries with like friends and family
and yeah yeah yeah it sounds to me like
um
just by the way i think you bring up a
great point if you're if you're living
an incredible meaningful life the these
sort of mundane
distractions even though you get that
dopamine rush it's going to seem so
weak in comparison to the strength of
of a of a meaningful life of course that
that does require a lot
more cerebration than celebration is
often what i'll say like we have to we
have to
we have to build up the strength of a of
a
well-lived life and constantly
pacifying ourselves or distracting
ourselves with the device
is not uh is not a way to do that in
fact that's how we atrophy
i think in many ways ryan talk about the
boundaries though
yeah he's talking about you know
sometimes it might feel harsh
and guess what it probably does brian
you picked up and moved to china
uh that's to some people that's going to
feel harsh as well
a few things that i would say and and
just knows i'm going to give this answer
but
you don't have to explain yourself to
anyone uh and and
as soon as you start to feel like you
you're compelled to explain yourself
remember you can step back and say i'm
this isn't a requirement
there may be times where i want to
but i don't need to be compelled to
explain
myself i don't have to tell you why i am
or i'm not using
facebook or why i am or i'm not using
instagram or whatever
and the other thing i'm going to tell
you is guess what most people
probably don't actually care ryan you
don't have a facebook account i'm sure
people aren't coming to you and saying
how dare you
no but you know when someone does come
to me and they say how dare you
with whatever boundary i set up which
happens every once in a while
sure you know i try to and i've said
this many times on the podcast before
i try to approach those tense situations
with the de-escalating attitude
and the way that you do that is you
focus on showing that person love
you focus on showing that person some
compassion or empathy or whatever you
want to call it
uh you want to show that person that you
respect them
that's what we want out of every
relationship every human human
interaction we want to feel good we want
to be loved
we want to be understood and we want to
be respected
so if you can keep those things in mind
when you're
talking about these boundaries with
other people they're probably
they're also probably going to
de-escalate now there are situations
where people
don't de-escalate and they just want to
continue to escalate well that's where
you walk away give it a little time and
then come back to it maybe
now jess social media is the place where
people escalate all the time
and you're so glad we have you to
de-escalate things yeah please be nice
to the youtube comments on monitoring
these
so let's talk about this because people
often escalate much more quickly there
it's like if ryan ryan i loved his
example there people want
love and support but on on social media
it's like well i'm just going to pull
out my switchblade
it's the equivalent of that right and
and so
i mean i guess why do we do that what
are your thoughts because you see it so
much
i think it's um a precarious situation
because everyone's at the table
every there's somebody like in mumbai
from the table
there like is a woman who like you know
picks rice in china there's like
somebody in russia at the table
and we have to be thoughtful of
everybody's feelings
that we don't even know what their
backgrounds are that's so hard like if
if somebody was in the room and i know
they had a situation that i should be
sensitive about i would be aware of it
but since everybody's in the room
we have to be thoughtful of that but
really what i think what it comes down
to is we are a product of our
experiences
and the more experiences we have the
more
broad of people that we become and i
think when you become
an open-minded person and you realize
that everyone's coming
to you with their resources and their
tools and their experiences
you realize there's a reason that they
are the way they are and there may they
may have something
in their past that you don't know about
that like if you had that same
experience you would feel the same way
so i think we really have to recognize
that like things are the way they are
for a reason
and you might not know that reason and
if you did you might even change your
mind
well that's what's great about feedback
or i think in the documentary they
they say criticism specifically mm-hmm
um
i mean he wrote a great book about what
10 reasons you should uh social media
and we could differentiate it
between criticism and feedback but
sometimes feedback feedback can have
some
criticism in it that isn't so sharp it's
not with the blade but long story short
is
when we get those experiences when
people point things out
it actually helps us present a better
argument yeah yeah
what i love what jessica's saying here
because it sounds like what you're
describing is compassion
and having compassion even for those who
are we call them seagulls
right because there's sean put a link to
that essay about
seagulls but uh they'll put it in show
notes but
uh seagulls fly over whatever you've
done they crap on it they fly away
that's what a that's what a seagull does
and we can even have compassion for them
now we'll still block you but in fact i
think blocking someone is often the most
compassionate thing you can do because
you're not allowing them to continue
their suffering
in your home right or in in your your
place of communication
it's like someone came into your house
and they're being belligerent
and you're self-harming yes and you're
basically saying
um you're not well you need to leave the
house you're not welcome in my home it
reminds me i think louis ck was on
fallon maybe and he was talking about uh
the way that people experience social
media
and the difference between between that
and real life interactions and if i say
something mean to you
and i look at your face and i see your
micro expressions and i realized that i
was just a jerk
like then that changes things and i
think that because of the fact that we
don't have that in-person
like visceral response to these negative
interactions
the block is the closest thing that we
have to it because when you go to that
page you have this visceral reaction of
like
the electronic version of a frown saying
like you made me feel bad and now
you're not allowed to talk to me anymore
and i think it's a beautiful boundary to
draw i love
one time one time i was gonna block
somebody and i sent
josh blocks a picture of blocks i'm like
we're gonna have a block party today
i think we may have posted the uh
organizing as well planned hoarding
essay that day
oh yeah some people get very mad about
what i always look at is some very sort
of innocuous words and then
what i find people get yeah people get
really angry about
these exceptions and and they
think that there aren't we're not
allowing exceptions for anything
and it's and it's like well there's
always no matter what philosophy you
look at like there's going to be an
exception to the rules that
that are laid out also i'm sorry i just
want to mention that i
also don't block everybody that's a jerk
because sometimes
i think it's i think it's valuable to
make sure that there's a conversation to
be had because if somebody else notices
that they're a jerk
and they're like hey i'm going to point
out to you that you were a jerk right
like
so i think that it's important to you
know leave
those conversations be because it
creates a dialogue
and that person needs that dialogue yeah
yes absolutely
you know what you just gave me an idea i
would love to take like
the most visceral conversation that we
can find on the internet
and then the skit is everyone in the
same room talking to each other
yeah like reading reading the comments
back and forth
to each other like that because you
would never do that if you were in the
same room with someone well
i would it would be even better if you
hire like well-known
actors to act it out oh yeah and they're
acting out these comments to each other
typos and all
i'll be so good yeah so this would be
really good patent-pending brian i'm
going to send you a copy of the
minimalist rule book you're asking about
boundaries well
one way to define a boundary is to call
them rules right
ryan and i came up with 16 rules for
living with
less it's a free ebook you can get it
the minimalists.com
resources there's also an audiobook
version of that available now as well
ryan and i recorded it we even did a
mini podcast
associated with each of the 16 rules so
you can check out
the free ebook version or the audiobook
version the
minimalists.com rulebook for the
audiobook version
and you can download the free ebook
there as well i'm gonna skip
anna's question actually we'll move it
over to the maximal
episode because i thought it was a good
question we're just running out of time
here
so ryan tell me what time it is you know
what time it is it is time for our
lightning round
yes thank you jess will we answer your
questions from your texts you can text
your questions and comments to
937-202-4654 yes indeed those tax go to
both of our phones we personally reply
to as many as we can
but we don't respond to everyone we do
respond to some
on this podcast though during the
lightning round so ryan and i
and now jess we all do our best to
answer every question with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maxims
in the show notes so you can copy and
share our pithy answers on social media
if you'd like
and now thanks to jessica you can find
all of our minimal maxims in one place
minimal maxims.com megan has a question
all right megan wants to know how do you
balance staying informed with spending
time in the moment
is there a secret algorithm to seeing
only the highlights
and the funny stuff so jess i did
try to separate this a little bit
earlier but like you have personal
accounts as well you're at jess breathes
on on all the
relevant social media platforms myspace
and tumblr wherever else she is
um so let's talk about balance
right because you do have social media
accounts on your phone out of necessity
here
um but how do you find balance
screenless saturdays yeah um i i find
balance because
what i'm looking for with screenless
saturdays what is this
is the space between stimuli and
response and i have a full 24 hours
every single week to um have a deeper
relationship with that space
and recognize the value in it but also
confront myself because i feel like
that's really what we're looking to do
here
is confront ourselves and we're looking
for like why am i searching for the
phone and i think that
so often we search for it but then we
don't we're not really paying attention
to the fact that there's something
that's
that's deeper going on so i really feel
that the value is looking
inward and stopping for a moment
and placing up those boundaries
parenting yourself i
i gesture to you because last night you
were like i gotta i'm i'm getting riled
up i gotta go to bed i'm white like i
gotta wind down oh yeah
that's right the value of parenting
yourself and and
looking at yourself because really like
you know
children when i see a child crying in
the store i can like relate
i'm like i kind of look at them and i'm
like yeah you know what i kind of feel
that way sometimes
so um so i so i think that we all have
like that person inside of us so i think
if we recognize that and we're aware of
the fact that that person is inside of
us
then we can um both be compassionate for
ourselves and draw effective boundaries
yeah i got something pithy for you and
maybe we can talk about it just briefly
here but
when she's asking how do you balance
staying in form of spending time
in the moment is there a secret
algorithm
to only the highlights and yes find out
on our maximal episode what that secret
algorithm is
um so so here's my pithy answer when
everything's important
nothing's important and
what i mean by that is we call a twitter
stream
for a reason or a social media stream
right imagine trying to consume every
drop of water in a river
or imagine just trying to touch every
drop of water in a river
you can't now if someone like me who has
ocd i'm a completist i would love i
try to catch up on things but i've i've
also surrendered and so
i think the word we're looking for here
is
surrender i think we have to surrender
to the fact that
we're missing out and it's okay in fact
the fear of missing out is the problem
not the missing out the missing out is
not a problem at all
miss out but miss out on the right thing
so you don't miss out
on the actually the things that are
actually important
yeah my pithy answer is this there is no
secret algorithm for discipline
and i wish it was as simple as you know
downloading an app
and although an app called discipline
sounds like there's something there
patent-pending but yeah these are things
that we have in our lives and
in in the social dilemma it talks about
how
this technology is you know growing way
faster than the way we're able to evolve
in fact we haven't involved at all since
this technology
so we have to come up with ways to
handle this technology ourselves and it
takes a lot of discipline
yeah yes it does all right well we've
got some listener tips some really great
listening tips today
also an added value segment you don't
want to miss out on unless
well but you don't have fear of missing
out you can miss out on if you want
right
but we do have a bunch more surprise
questions a bunch more surprise
questions this week
here are some of them what are two
things you can do right now to improve
your relationship with your smartphone
do smartphones make us dumb we've got an
article about that
also what's the best way to ditch your
smartphone if that's something you're
trying to do
what are the three biggest problems with
the documentary the social dilemma
how do you build a screen time budget
and what's the best
digital declutter experiment what are
the consequences of ryan
unfollowing everyone on social media i
can't wait to answer that one
uh if you had to use only one social
media platform what should it be
i'm gonna be talking to jess about that
also is social media
essential to run a business that's a
good one too plus a million more
questions for jessica
and the minimalist and if you want to
hear all that subscribe to our maximal
episodes on the minimalist private
podcast it's a completely separate
podcast
and it's the most honest way for the
minimalists to earn an income
because we don't believe in ads by the
way if you're not a private podcast
subscriber
you're literally missing out on two
thirds of
what we create so just be aware of that
you can try it out just for a week or a
few weeks or a month
what we're trying to do is add immense
value to your life in fact i have a
quote here
from a new patreon supporter she says oh
my god i
just pasted this in from from patreon oh
my god these episodes
absolutely blew my mind i just had to
pause and come here to write this
comment
this private episode is all together on
a different level compared to the public
one
great work i love it the reason being is
and jess tell me about this
our our maximal episodes ryan and i know
they're different but how are they
different to you
i think they're different to me in the
sense that you seem like you can be more
free there
and i i think obviously if you have
somebody that's paying for your work i
think that
if you look at it that's really the
issue with social media is there
i think we're if if we were if we had
um advertisers then our audience
would be the product yeah and i think
that that's
really when we're talking about the fact
that advertisements suck and we don't
have advertisements on the podcast
that's why
is because we want to be the one group
of
individuals that say you are not a
product that you are something more than
that
yeah and by the way what we have to do
is continue to add value to you and the
places that advertise
don't have to necessarily add value they
just need to get your eyeballs
onto their service because you are the
product as you alluded to
so head on over to the minimalists.com
support to subscribe and
get your personal links so that our
private podcast plays in your favorite
podcast
app ryan what else you got for us this
week here are some voicemail comments
and tips from our listeners
check them out hi there my name is amy i
live in the san francisco bay area
i just wanted to
mention something that helps me with
social media with facebook
and i would love to eliminate facebook
just like you've talked about on your
podcast
and would love to eliminate it but i
still have to keep it because i use it
for work
purposes i teach classes
to kids and i need i communicate
with the parents through facebook i talk
about new classes
etc so i'm keeping facebook
but i can't stand the news feed it's
very distracting
and annoying so what i've done to help
me
is i have downloaded a news feed
eradicator and i've done that for my
phone
and my computer and you can find lots of
you can find different news feed
eradicators
if you do a search online i use feedless
that's i use feedless for my phone
and basically what happens is you go
onto facebook
and the whole news feed just the news
feed
is eliminated and sometimes some of that
these newsfeed eradicators also have a
little quote
um for the day um
instead of the news feed so
and it's just so much more helpful if i
need to
look up and see what somebody's doing i
can do that
i can just manually do that through
facebook but it doesn't have
all of that annoying news feed
hi josh and ryan my name is hope and i'm
from louisville kentucky
i'm calling in regards to your recent
podcast episode about book clutter
almost any time that you mention your
book you encourage your readers to
minimize them once they are done with
them
i want to suggest a fun way to do that
in louisville i've seen several book
exchange boxes in different coffee shops
where you can leave old books you
finished and pick up a new one without
having to go to the library
if you're a minimalist but don't want
your friends and family to feel like
you're trying to
convert them maybe consider leaving one
of joshua ryan's books in an exchange
box instead
this way you can rest assured that the
next recipient of the book is someone
who is choosing to learn about
minimalism for themselves
if your city doesn't have book exchange
boxes maybe you can bring this concept
to it
all right y'all thanks again to jessica
lynn williams yeah thanks for being here
absolutely that's awesome you can check
her out on social media we'll put a link
to
her handles in the show notes if you'd
like
our added value this week we've been
talking a little bit about um
self-destructive behavior and and social
media
uh i think contributes to some
accidental self-destructive behavior in
fact i think most of the time
whenever i mean think about your 20s
ryan or my 20s
i barely remember my 20s exactly
and so remember though that when you
start a self-destructive behavior it
never feels self-destructive at first
oh yeah right it feels like uh escape or
getaway or whatever
and before we know it all of a sudden
we're we're steeped
in self-destruction there's a new album
out by mgk
and it's called tickets to my downfall
which and he's this 29 year old
i guess you would just call him like a
rapper from ohio but he started he he
he made this what i would call a 90s
alternative rock album
which is it seems like a strange
combination it seems like a rapper
couldn't do that
but he did it exceptionally well it it
um
is the album you sent me yeah it is i
don't know if you checked it out yet but
um my favorite song is there's a ton of
great songs on there but it is an album
he's a 29 year old guy who
is yeah i wrote a novel um a decade and
a half ago called as a decade fades
and i finished it when i was 29 and a
lot of it was about sort of
self-destructive
behavior right and i see a lot of that
those same characteristics and mgk and
what he's writing about and how he can't
get out of his own
way and i see i see the parallels right
now with social media we can't get
out of our own way and the only way for
us to
to sort of repair ourselves is to
realize that
we're really screwed i mean and
someone's not going to come in and and
regulate you
to toward freedom now i'm not saying
regulation isn't needed with respect to
social media
it is but you can't wait around for the
regulation
self regulation is what's important here
so if you realize you're screwed
then you also have to realize you have
to save yourself and
you we have this whole term vote with
your dollars but now in this
in this attention economy it's vote with
your attention
yeah and realize that if you're giving
your attention to these platforms for a
disproportionate
amount of time then you're voting
for their business model and so you
don't have to completely opt out
but you have to walk away for extended
periods of time otherwise you're going
to see some self-destructive
behavior and so check out the new mgk
album it's called tickets to my downfall
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalists
ryan had this idea over a year ago that
whenever
whenever we have a guest in here so jess
when we're all finished with this we can
get you to do one of these as well
we have this new video series called
biggest failure and it's talking about
each person comes on and says you know
hi i'm
joshua fields milburn and this is my
biggest failure and then we'd sort of
talk about the lesson that we learned
from failing
and ryan you sort of had this idea
because i i think i want to change the
narrative even the sort of social media
narrative in a way of
constant winning yeah i really think
that in western culture
there is this narrative with uh with
celebrities or with
you know radio personalities with social
media personalities i'm trying not to
use the word influencer here
um but what they do is they talk about
like well hey here's where
uh i messed up in life and then here's
how i started to win
and here is how i win tomorrow and
here's how i make sure i win
from five years from now and i'm going
to be winning the rest of my life and
you can win with me too
yeah and there's just something about
that that is
i got excited
it's a little phony it's not real life
yeah and i think what the biggest
failure segment does is it really
takes us uh to the truth of some things
and to me that's the truth is more
important
than uh just people constantly seeing me
or seeing our guests as just
constant winners by the way i think
these these
it's a video series and by the way it's
only on our uh patreon
page the minimalists dot com slash
patreon or patreon.com
the minimalist either way we'll get you
there every saturday we put these out
they show up in your email inbox no
calls to you if you are a
podcast supporter but what i've noticed
jess is that
this resonates with a lot of people
because we all fail
and we all have sort of bruises or scars
but i think our scars make up
the most interesting parts of us
and so with this video series
it's two to five minutes each week and
it's just this little nugget of like oh
this person
failed their way to success because
that's how everyone
succeeds by the way we know this as a
child
right whenever you see a kid first
trying to walk it's not like
well i got up and fell and so i guess i
tried that once and now i'm done
but as adults it's like well i uh
screwed that up let's hide that and make
sure no one ever sees that screw up ever
again
a kid falls and they're like get right
back up i'm
going like like how how long do you give
a kid
to walk well just until they they can
actually walk right i mean it's not the
you're not gonna say well you've tried
four or five times like what are you
doing ella like
you're just gonna be relegated to
crawling for the rest of your life
no you're gonna fail until you figure
this out and that's what we're trying to
capture here with
these with with this video series called
biggest failures we'll put a link to it
in the show notes put a link to the most
recent one in there
but every saturday they come out show up
right in your inbox if you are
a podcast supporter patreon.com the
minimalist
you can follow the minimalist on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalist come to one of our live
podcast shows visit theminimalists.com
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast email a voice memo to
podcasts at theminimalists.com
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalist if you
want our show notes
in your inbox sign up for our email list
over at the minimalists.com
we'll never send you spam or junk or
advertisements or anything like that
but we will send you our simple sunday
emails whenever we send those in
addition to our
podcast show notes every week and if you
leave here today with just one message
we hope it's this jessica love people
and use things because the opposite
never works love it all right y'all see
you later
see ya every little thing
you think that you need every little
thing
you think that you need every little
thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine without it
[Music]